كلفت وزاره الدفاع الفلبينيه الجيشا
بتعزيز وجوده في بحر جنوب الصين بعد رصد
انشطه صينيه في مياه متنازع عليها قرب
جزيره استراتيجيه تسيطر عليها الفلبين
وياتي بيان الوزاره في عقاب تقرير افاد
بقيام الصين باعمال تشييد في نقاط غير
ماهوله في جزر استراتلي المتنازع عليها
وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان اي ان اي تعدد
او اعلان تعبئه تباعيه لاي نقاط او مناطق
في نطاق الاقتصاديه الخالصه للفلبين يمثل
تهديدا لامن جزيره باجازه التي هي جزء من
الاراضي التابعه لسياده الفلبين وحتى
البيان بيجين على الالتزام بالنظام الدولي
القائم على احترام القواعد والانتناع عن
اي اعمال من شانها ان تفاقم التوترات
من جهتها نفس وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
موجوده ما وصفتها بمحطات شرطيه خارج الصين
وذلك ردا على تقارير افادت بوجود مراكز
للشرطه السريه تابعه لبيجي واكدت الناطقته
باسم الوزاره ان على الصين ان الصين
ملتزمه بعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول الاجنبيه